Ну сьогодні вся країна волонтерить все
тримається на
укрволонтерпромі все тримається на
мінволонтері ми Нам треба допомагати
волонтерам а не ставити палки в колеса
Ну що ми робимо Чим там думав наш Уряд
коли на таку зробив систему яку пройти
неможливо Ну давайте ще заберемо
сьогодні ви забрали кошти в місцевої
влади допомагати військовим давайте ще
уряд забере можливість волонтерам
завозити підтримку військовим Що ми
робимо Взагалі І в той же час ми
говоримо Ми віримо в перемогу так треба
працювати та хоча б навіть не заважати
перша заповідь лікаря ноноцере не
нашкодь не можеш хоч щось добре зробити
так нешкодь А в нас якесь шкідництво